good morning everybody I'm really glad
to be here and I'm really glad that
you're here too as Kurt told you I'm
gonna start by telling you a little bit
about how I got interested in science
and I I grew up as he says he said I
grew up in Virginia in Charlottesville
Virginia and both of my parents were
scientists they were both actually
people who had gotten degrees in
chemistry and so there was a lot of
science kind of just in the air in my in
my family growing up and I think I knew
pretty early on that I wanted to be a
scientist and and go into research there
was one moment that made a really big
difference to me when I was growing up I
was about 11 years old my father came
home on a Sunday afternoon he had been
at his lab for the last 48 hours about
the whole weekend he had been working
really hard doing a big experiment and I
remember him walking in the door looking
exhausted but kind of happy and I said
hi dad and he sort of flopped down on
the couch and he said we learned
something today that nobody else in the
world knows we discovered something
today that nobody else knows and I
thought wow my dad could do that I
wonder I wonder if I could do that and
the fact of the matter is that anybody
in this room can do that simply by being
energetic and curious and working hard
that's one of the things I want to
stress today is that anybody can do that
and that was a crucial moment because I
thought to myself wouldn't that be
amazing to know even one thing for five
minutes that nobody else on the planet
knew a fact about nature about how the
world works wouldn't that be amazing so
I was interested in science I think
pretty much from that point on I wanted
to do research I lived
discovered and it went on and and and
got my PhD and then came to Yale and
I've been here for twenty two and a half
years now and I've been studying the
same thing for much of that time and you
know why not want to say another thing
you don't have to get interested in
science just because your parents are
interested in science now just a little
anecdote my daughter who happens to be
sitting up in the top row today she
wasn't particularly interested in
science until she got a great biology
teacher in tenth grade and it really
turned her on so that's another great
way to get interested in science is the
motivational inspirational teacher who
just brings a subject alive for you so
welcome and support those teachers
because they're really important people
or so for more than 22 years I've been
thinking about the genetics of the
immune system and how we fight disease
and the amazing weird and strange things
that happen when our immune system
fights off infections so let's start by
just thinking about what is the immune
system well it's a whole group of cells
in our body many of them are white blood
cells floating around in our blood
but there's other kinds as well and they
all work together to prevent protect us
from the germs that would make us sick
and what you're looking at here is us is
a slice of skin and the skin cells are
colored blue and the immune cells are
either green or red two different kinds
of immune cells and the point I want to
make here is the immune system is
everywhere in your body it's in your
skin it's in your blood it's in your
organs some of the cells are floating
around some of them like these cells are
just sitting in one place vigilant
waiting for the germs to come along so
they can protect you so that's the whole
purpose of the immune system to protect
us from these nasty germs germs okay
what will
you think of germs one of the two major
kinds of germs you think of yeah viruses
and bacteria I could not have given a
better answer thank you these are the
guys there are lots of different kinds
of bacteria some of them are beneficial
to us some of them cause disease like
these guys Salmonella anthrax cholera
now what you're looking at here is
obviously this isn't the size of real
bacteria this is looking through a
high-powered microscope these are tiny
tiny things that could not be seen with
the naked eye these are tiny little guys
but when they get into our bodies they
can cause serious illness and of course
viruses many many different kinds of
viruses they cause a wide range of
diseases some of them for example could
cause the flu
some of them cause AIDS the common cold
etc one of the things I want to stress
about these bacteria and viruses is that
they are ever-changing they are mutating
they are morphing into other forms and
germs are unpredictable that's a
fundamental feature of the world in
which we live that we cannot predict
what's going to come along next and
might threaten our health and so the
immune system has to deal with this
problem of the intrinsic
unpredictability of nature and of the
germs so how does it do that that's a
fundamental question we're gonna think
about today all right so what is the
immune system I told you it's a whole
bunch of different cells and again
looking through a big powerful
microscope there's a whole bunch of
different types of cells in the immune
system one we're not going to talk about
most of them the only thing I want you
to know is there's lots of different
types of cells and they work together in
this beautifully orchestrated flood
to protect you when you get an infection
they talk to each other they communicate
they send signals they tell each other
to go go go stop stop stop faster slower
the immune system is this incredible web
of cells floating around in your body
that could all talk to one another today
we're going to talk about a particular
kind of cell the B cell and the B cell
is just one of the cells it's not more
important than the others but it's very
important and we're going to talk about
it because it does the most amazing
things to its genes that I've ever come
across anywhere in nature or in science
okay so the B cell what does the B cell
do does anybody know why a B cell is
important it produces something yeah no
that's exactly right the B cell produces
the antibody now the antibody you don't
need to know the details about the
antibody the antibody is a molecule that
floats around in our blood and it's
whole job floating around in the blood
is to grab on to bacteria and viruses
and to neutralize them so they cannot
infect us Oh ant by grabbing on them
them sometimes it helps to clear them
from our body to bring them into cells
that digest them all up and chew them up
they're gone okay so the antibody is a
very important protective molecule
floating around in our blood and it
grabs on to bacteria and viruses
using the tips of the molecule out here
there's one grabbing region here and
another here and they're identical to
one another and it uses these loops at
the end that form a sort of shape that
can grab onto bacteria and viruses we're
going to come back to this point in a
minute okay so that's the whole point of
the ant about each antibody can grab in
two places and this is
a little schematic you see that diagram
there that's the little schematic that
I'm going to use throughout the whole
talk to represent an antibody okay yeah
how many people have had say the flu or
a cold this winter yeah quite a few how
many of you sort of suspect that you
caught it from someone you know yeah
that's kind of the way these things work
is these germs are smart they figured
out how to get into one person and then
get to the next person and get to the
next person so this is going to
illustrate one of the key points about
the immune system and we're going to
talk about today so these are my two
people okay here are my two people and
they're perfectly happy and they let's
say they go to school together or they
work in the same place or they're
members of the same family or whatever
okay and they're very happy they're
running around and then one of them gets
a virus Oh feel very good right and
bummed-out sneeze sneeze etc and friend
comes running over oh I'm sorry you feel
right and so by the time this person
feels sick probably already given the
virus to this person right so this
person gets sick and goes home and
doesn't go to school the next day
this person runs around for a while oh I
feel fine very good right starts to get
sick oh and then this person by the time
they're sick they've given it to
somebody else and they've given it to
somebody else who's given it to somebody
else but then during all that process
this person feels better yay and comes
back to school and the virus is going
around from person to person to person
and this person comes back to school and
gets the virus again right because what
goes around comes around
it comes back to this person and
wouldn't it stink if this person got
sick again
it's a terrible goes home for another
four days we if that's what if that's
the way it worked we would be sick about
half or three quarters of our lives
because the viruses go around and the
bacteria go around and they get
transmitted and they flow out but the
fact of the matter is that we don't
spend three-quarters of our lives sick
and that's what I want to impress upon
you today is that that's that's what I
want you to understand at the end of
this lecture is why we aren't sick all
the time so there's two imperatives the
immune system yes I don't need my people
anymore
there's two imperatives of the immune
system the first is this is really
important you have to survive the first
infection the first time the virus comes
along you have to just survive right
because you're you're no use dead and
you get sick and that's not good but at
least you survive and the second thing
is that the immune system has to
remember the first infection so you
don't get sick the second time and that
is what we refer to as memory the memory
of the immune system or any illogical
memory and this is what I want you to
understand today how does that work now
you know how memory in your up and your
brain works you can remember your
friends name or your address your phone
number things like that but the immune
system remembering how would that work
the answer lies in large part with the
b-cells and the fundamental aspect of
b-cells that is so important is that
there are a whole lot of them anybody
have a guess as to how many b-cells
they're all in our body got a guess of a
million now it's a good guess that I
have a higher guess can I
more money bet on this B cell yeah we've
gotten up to a billion what do you think
two million that's going down from a
billion anybody else oh you've already
made your you already made your bid yep
a trillion all we've exceeded our limit
here the answer and these are very you
want to get to guess how many you wow
that's more cells than we've got in our
whole body that's not fair
the answer is very roughly about 10
billion 10 billion B cells floating
around in our body and in case you were
wondering that's a 1 with 10 zeros after
it and I made a very rough calculation I
figure that if you took a very small
jellybean and you took out all the
chairs of people in this room and you
filled this room with small jellybeans
that's about how many jellybeans would
fit in this room whew that's a lot of B
cells and they're all floating around in
our body right now ok here's a
fundamentally important thing each B
cell we just
okay cuz I want to have this picture up
so you can always look at it except
that's not the way it should look it
should be huh that's like the slideshow
hasn't been started oh well alright you
can basically see the the antibody here
I want you to be able to look at the
antibody if anybody can make that
project properly that'd be great okay so
the a very important thing about the B
cells is that each B cell makes a
different antibody and how is it
different it's different in its germ
grabbing region right out here right at
the tips each antibody is different it
has a different shape it's a different
grabbing shape now now think about what
I just said and I said that there are 10
billion B cells and each one makes a
different antibody so therefore how many
antibodies must there be ten billion
whoa hold on here now why is that why is
that a puzzle how is it possible to make
10 billion different antibodies well
there's something very special about
antibodies and it's a big mystery and
puzzle at first this question of how we
could possibly make 10 million different
antibodies was a real dilemma at first I
want to explain that that that puzzle or
paradox and the answer lies in our genes
all right so let's step back after we
have - now where what is a gene ah let's
this is a cartoon of a cell and in the
middle of the cell is the nucleus inside
the nucleus are the chromosomes now
what's a chromosome all right they are
very very long sort of strings of DNA
all right there's DNA going along it
goes all the way off that's AG that's
way off that side and those chromosomes
are packed into the nucleus of all of
ourselves
G
is lie on the antibodies there's a lie
along the chromosome there's the first
Union second gene 13-14 along all of our
chromosomes are genes now what is a gene
the gene you can think of as an
instruction manual for how to make the
bits and pieces of ourselves all the
different bits and pieces of ourselves
the information for how to make those
bits and pieces is encoded in the
individual genes okay that's good
now each gene typically provides the
instruction for how to make one thing
okay so you could have a gene that makes
something that's important for energy
production you can't have another gene
that makes a messenger and you can have
another gene that makes a pump or a
connector all the different things that
make up all of our organs and ourselves
and everything is encoded and instructed
in our genes
well how many genes do we have anybody
you have a rough idea how many genes we
have along our chromosomes yeah back
there more than 10 million wow that's a
big number
yup the ten billion guess from the back
no guests back there yeah
ten trillion genes well you know what
these are very reasonable yep 10,000 I'm
liking what I'm hearing here you would
be it would make a lot of sense to think
that we would have billions of genes
because I told you we have billions of
the ANA but the answer is we have about
20,000 genes on that's all the genes we
have on all of our chromosomes so we got
a problem here folks
each gene makes one thing and there's
20,000 of them but I told you of 10
billion antibodies question
whoa are you a mind reader
you sure Wow
maybe you should come up and give this
talk all right well hold on to that
thought because we're just about there
any other questions while we're pausing
for brilliant inspirational things yeah
that's a great idea and that's where we
go and thank you very much all right
so the paradox and back in the 1960s and
70s scientists were really wrestling
with this they knew we had tons of
antibodies they knew we had too many
antibodies to be encoded what one
antibody per gene it just wasn't
possible and so the answer to this
puzzle is that the genes that make
antibodies are not normal genes they're
the weirdest genes on the planet and
they're the reason I got interested in
immunology in the first place when I
heard about this I thought yeah and
that's what I want to work on when I
have my own lab and that's what have
worked on for my whole career is this is
sort of the antibody genes they are not
normal genes and the weird thing about
antibody genes is they are broken up
into pieces and they can't make anything
so an antibody gene looks something like
this
piece one piece two piece 3 4 or 5 6 etc
so there's hundreds of pieces and as I
told you this gene right here can't make
anything so you're thinking that is
really weird and kind of stupid right
why would you have a gene that can't
make anything the answer is that by
breaking it up into pieces exactly as
was suggested by the scientists back
there in the in the in the auditorium is
that several pieces can be joined
together to now make a functional
complete gene so for example piece one
could be joined to piece three
these three could be joint the piece six
and when that happens one three and six
are now together and that's an assembled
antibody gene that can allow the
production of an antibody now the
fundamental cool thing about this is
that there are hundreds of little pieces
of the gene and there are many different
ways of putting them together so now a
piece 116 etc and each b-cell puts the
pieces together a little differently and
each different way of putting them
together gives you a different antibody
with a different shape where to go my
shape is gone nope nope that wasn't what
I wanted
huh all right well we've lost our
antibody that's too bad
I cannot make it come back easily all
right that doesn't matter these antibody
each b-cell puts the pieces together a
little differently so that remember that
grabbing place out at the end of the
antibody that's different in each
antibody and so each b-cell has a
different one of those so by using the
power of combinations we can make
billions of different antibodies now
I've just told you something that you
should be sitting there thinking hold on
how do you do that how do you put pieces
of DNA together we've lost and no maybe
it just went to the third slide or
something weird how do you put pieces of
DNA together so I need for volunteers to
help me with this demo okay yeah come on
up one two yeah you want to come up come
on up no just just over there is perfect
one two three three yeah come on three
and four all right so would you do me a
favor of holding this end right and here
you're gonna hold this end thank good
now this piece don't pull don't pull too
tight or we're gonna have a problem here
all right move move a little bit out
that way there you go perfect this is
not a jump rope no no and you guys come
on underneath all right now what this
represents pull out a little bit more so
it goes a little bit taller what this
green tubing represents is a chromosome
this is DNA this is the chromosome and
it runs this isn't the whole chromosome
it's just a little bit of the chromosome
and this is one of the antibody gene
pieces here this red and that orange is
one of the ones over there now the way
this works here you grab on here
don't pull yet and you grab on here all
right the way this works the way the
antibody genes are put together is that
molecular scissors come along and cut
the chromosome so here you grab here and
there and pull hold onto the ends don't
let go right here one hand here and one
in there and pull now these are my
molecular scissors
they have cut the DNA they they have had
the audacity to cut this chromosome in
two pieces so now it's broken and I will
take this and this this piece of your
chromosome is chop suey it's going to be
thrown away and discarded and lost from
that particular B cell it's gone that's
a sort of another audacious thing to do
hey that was mom or dad's DNA you just
threw away their right for that
particular B cell now you guys come
closer together the ends have to come in
a little bit here and some other
proteins come along and they put the
chromosome back together hold on and so
now segment one is joined the segment
three or whatever it is and the antibody
gene has been put together by cutting
the chromosome and then sticking it back
together and and free throwing away part
of the chromosome a separate big hand
for our volunteers well thanks Dave
now yeah that's that that's not all I
mean it happens more than once in a
given B cell to put all put everything
together but that's how you join one
piece of DNA to another and each B cell
does that a little bit differently with
different combinations and so that's how
you get these billions of different
antibodies all right so bring on the
germs we're ready for them we've got ten
billion B cells floating around in our
body in various places and now we get
infected let's say it's the flu let's
gets the virus that causes the common
cold okay this guy down here let's say
it's that old Rhino virus and it's going
to give us a cold and we get infected
and I just told you we have 10 billion B
cells each with a different antibody now
I'd like to ask for 10 billion
volunteers but we don't have that many
and we couldn't all fit in the room we
couldn't even fit that many jellybeans
in the room right so I'm going to do a
simple demonstration with 4 new
volunteers yeah back there in the back
yep go ahead 2 3 4
I can't split you apart
all right so these guys coming up here
are going to show what happens when we
get infected with a virus all right so
you hold on to that you're going to be a
b-cell and you're gonna be a b-cell and
you're going to be a b-cell and you are
going to be the virus you okay with that
yeah all right you're cool hold it like
that
it's important you stand over here
alright cuz you're the virus and you
haven't gotten into the body yet but
you're gonna don't worry all right
here's my B cells now you see what
they're holding hold them up so
everybody can see what they've got right
here is their antibody but it's not the
whole antibody what they're actually
showing you is just a very cartoonish
representation of the shape right out
here at the end of the antibody and
you'll notice that each one of them is a
different shape right and that's the if
they're floating around in the body do
we do to do and then virus comes along
come on virus right he comes along and
he starts don't get too aggressive here
virus and bumping into B cells now you
will notice that when he bolts into this
particular T cell that is a really lousy
fit right hold on to that so that does
not fit very well and so when the virus
bumps into that B cell they don't stick
together oh yeah here you guys tilt it
so that the audience can see there you
go that's a bad fit and so this B cell
wanders away
Guddu and you don't care anymore you're
not interested in that fire sorry let's
try you okay so hold it up so the you
can see that's another really lousy fit
and so that B cell goes wandering away
floats away in the blood do did you do
now this B cell comes along and
especially if we have turned the right
way
whoo-hoo then you will notice the
antibody and the virus have a pretty
good fit
everybody see that it's not a perfect
fit and I'm going to come back to that
but because this is a pretty good fit
this particular b-cell is now going to
become activated wild and crazy and
start to divide and make copies of
herself and I apologize to the parents
maybe having a hundred of her would be a
little overwhelming but that's what
would happen if she were a b-cell now
she would start to divide and make lots
of copies of herself now here is a
various illustrates an extremely
important point different viruses have
different shapes on their surface
different bacteria have different shapes
they're always changing those shapes
around to try to fool our immune system
but because we have a billion of these
guys there are so many shapes over here
that no matter what the bacterium or
virus does over here we have a b-cell
over here
with an antibody that will be a pretty
good fit that's why having 10 billion is
so important not because every b-cell is
useful but because you never know what
nature's going to throw at you next okay
big hand for our volunteers thank you
park any questions about that so far
yeah okay so it's a good question if
people have a weak immune system could
it be that they just don't have enough
b-cells and hold so they don't have
enough shapes that's one explanation for
a weak immune system there's about a
thousand different ways your immune
system can be weak or not function
properly and in fact that's one of them
there are people who are born with that
don't produce enough b-cells and hence
don't have protection against germs it's
a great question yeah another question
that is a great question what if what if
there were more than 10 billion
different kinds of germs and they came
up with shapes that we just didn't have
an animal if there was no antibody for
that particular shape all I can say is
that I would rather not live on that
planet because that would be a whole lot
of germs and it might not be a very
friendly world our world has lots and
lots and lots but fortunately not quite
that many and thus far no one has found
a germ yet that our antibodies and
b-cells couldn't latch on to so it's a
great question yeah yeah that's a great
question if you've got ten billion and
there's one little virus over here
how does number you know 625 who find
its way to the virus well the the demo
that I just gave has one little flaw
which is that there was only one virus
but when you get infected with a virus
it makes lots of copies of itself it
gets transported around the body in
various ways and so the immune system is
set up with its piping and it's flows
that works to bring the infectious agent
into contact with lots of b-cells so
that dramatically increases the chance
of the appropriate b-cell finding the
the virus of the bacterium that's a
great question yeah
yeah how it latching on to this guy okay
we'll remember what you're looking at
here is it's it's a high magnification
view but it's not super high
magnification if you blew it up a bunch
more times you would start to see
individual molecular shapes on the
surface of this bacterium and those are
the things that the antibody would be
latching yeah this looks kind of smooth
like nothing to grab on to but but it
does have some shapes you just can't see
it because it's not blown up enough
everything has molecules and shapes on
its surface I gotta take a couple more
questions and then I'll move on
yeah where's a great question so there's
some diseases that our immune system
gets flummoxed by and just can't get rid
of the classic is the HIV virus and the
problem with HIV is that it's not that
our antibodies can't latch on to it
two things happen in HIV the first is
that the HIV virus mutates very rapidly
and so it's constantly changing the
shapes on its surface so a good antibody
one day suddenly isn't such a good
antibody the next day because the virus
has changed the second thing that
happens is that this virus kills a
particular other kind of immune cell in
our body called a t-cell and it turns
out that weren't about to show you is
requires the help of t-cells I wasn't
going to go into that in this lecture
but because the T cells are killed by
the virus the B cells don't do their job
and so there's two big problems with HIV
you lose an important type of cell and
the virus is constantly changing one
right so another question I'll take in
the one er
one more question yet asthma and cancer
yeah they don't go away and it's a
bummer asthma is as actually a situation
where instead of having too little
immune system activity in a way you've
got too much the the parts of the lungs
where the air is going through tend to
swell and get congested because of too
much activity of some cells in the
immune system so asthma is an example of
something where you'd like to make
everything kind of settle down and go to
sleep
cancer is a very interesting example
because actually our immune system is
good at fighting cancer cells but the
cancer cells are sometimes very clever
and turn on signals that tell the immune
system to go to sleep and one of the
most exciting things that's happening
actually at over at Yale Medical School
in our department right now is we're
learning how to turn and wait turn the
immune system back on wake up the immune
cells again and say don't stop fighting
the cancer go go go and there have been
some amazing promising results by waking
up the immune system again when the
cancers been trying to put it to sleep
so worse I mean I just want to emphasize
this of all the knowledge that there is
we have this much of it right now a tiny
tiny little thin sliver of it there is
so much it seems like we know so much
but there's so much more to know and
that's why we need new scientists and
people with curiosity and energy to come
and help make these discoveries because
we're
just at the beginning of understanding
how the cancer cells evade the the
action of our immune system so thank you
for asking that question I've actually
wanted to say something about cancer
okay let me let me go on I'll take some
more questions at the at the end and at
other points okay
so let's remember our three volunteers
here and our virus and you'll remember
there was the one b-cell that fit with
the virus and here it is here's the
b-cell and it's binding to the virus
using its antibody and this is the one
that's a good fit and I told you it
starts dividing right so one cell makes
two two cell makes two cells make four
and if you just keep going you get a lot
of b-cells and notice that every single
one of these b-cells
is making the same antibody as the
original b-cell so they're all good
b-cells that fit the virus well so now
we have lots of b-cells with the good
antibody and this takes some time it
takes a few days as these B cells
dividing and some of them are going to
differentiate they're gonna turn it into
sort of another type of b-cell and
they're going to become what are known
as antibody factories and they're gonna
pump instead of having the antibody
decorating the surface of the cell like
this they're now going to pump the
antibody out of the B cell and it's
going to be antibodies floating in the
blood and those little bodies floating
in the blood are what are going to help
us get rid of the virus now because this
all took some time you you you get sick
right you don't immediately get rid of
the virus you get sick and there's
another thing about these antibodies you
remember that when these guys came
together it was a pretty good fit but
it's actually not a perfect fit and so
there's another group of these B cells
that do something quite remarkable they
try to make a bed
unibody no i think well why would you
want to make a better antibody he just
found one that was a pretty good fit and
the answer is these good antibodies this
guy here is a pretty good antibody these
good antibodies are not a perfect fit
and they don't hold on to the virus
tightly and therefore some of the
viruses can escape the antibody infect
ourselves and multiply so here's a nice
illustration of that here's the antibody
binding on two different virus particles
that are running around in our in our
blood and this guy says you weren't
having every good fit you're not perfect
and I escaped and I'm gonna multiply ha
and you get sick okay so it actually
would be useful very useful to have a
better antibody that grabbed the virus
even more tightly and didn't let it
escape and didn't allow us to get sick
so how the heck are we gonna make a
better antibody how do we do this I mean
this is this is this is a tricky problem
it's pretty good but how are we gonna
oh are you reading my mind again what
are you gonna going to say
you know what I'm I I give up you want
to give back that's brilliant that's
exactly right
look but let me get there first Wow okay
thank you that's that's a great idea
let's let's see about that okay so how
do we make the better unibody the answer
we have to go back to the gene that
makes the antibody now if we're going
back to the gene here and here's that
gene remember it's been put together
with the molecular scissors and puts the
segment's together and we have our
assembled antibody gene and here's the B
cell it has a pretty it has a good
antibody but one of them a that wants to
make it better and so what it does is it
turns on a mutator which I'm going to
represent as M so here's the B cell with
this mutator inside it in its nucleus
and that mutator finds its way by
mechanisms we're just starting to
understand - the antibody gene and it
acts on the antibody gene and it changes
one unit of the DNA code in the antibody
gene just one just one unit of the code
now when you change the code in the gene
remember the gene is the instruction
manual for making this antibody when you
change the code you can change the shape
of the antibody and so let's think about
what the possible outcomes are there are
three possible outcomes anybody want to
want to offer some some options here yep
whoa that's right that's possible it's
absolutely anybody else other
suggestions yep yep it could make yeah
okay so here's our three possibilities
so she just suggested the antibodies
could get worse right right and you can
just imagine what the virus is thinking
having a sucker right you're not getting
me all right and we're gonna call that a
bad mutation right all right so what's
it what's another possibility we've had
we've had somebody suggested it could
get work somebody suggested it could get
better yeah right you could have a
change in the gene that makes no
difference well let's get this guy back
up here all right it's it's that it
changed it changed the protein a little
bit but actually the shape out here at
the tip didn't really change and so
there's no change and then as somebody
suggested oh yeah and the virus system a
huh nice try you didn't get any better
and then there's the third possibility
the antibody gets better it binds to the
virus more tightly yeah these are rare
mutations that make it better but now it
just changes the shape a little bit so
that it's going to fit that virus even
better and now you can imagine the virus
think and oh right because here is an
antibody that's even better at grabbing
on and it's not going to be able to get
loose yeah question
how does it know which one to change the
amazing thing is it hasn't got a clue
the mutations are random they're
happening in many many many B cells each
B cell gets a different mutation I think
that's okay where that's a good mutation
right good and bad
so mutations make amazing things happen
these B cells there's lots of B cells
that are mutating each one getting a
different mutation so imagine these guys
are the ones that just happen to get a
whole bunch of different mutations but
they were all bad right and so their
antibody is now not as good as by at
binding the virus and then there's some
B cells up here that get mutations that
have no effect and then there's the
lucky guys here that get mutations that
are the good mutations and now just like
changing the color on representing that
these are binding to the virus even more
tightly it's a better fit so the answer
to your question is they don't have a
clue as to what a good mutation or a bad
mutation is they just make a whole bunch
of mutations one in a whole bunch of
different B cells and hope that one of
them or one or more of them is going to
be a good mutation so again it relies on
having lots of B cells to do these
mutations in now here's the amazing
thing
while this mutation is happening the B
cells are still dividing and the really
cool thing is that the B cells with a
good mutation divide faster and they
survive better so what does that look
like after the cells have divided a few
times you see that the number of these
guys that the bad mutation has gone down
these guys have there are some of them
still and these guys are starting to
take over there's more of these but the
mutator keeps going it keeps mutating
the antibody genes and you could imagine
mutations that are good and bad and all
the rest let's imagine a couple of these
cells get another good mutation that
makes the fit even better so that now
these guys are even better than the red
ones the blue is even better than the
red and the cells keep dividing and the
ones with the better mutation they
divide even faster and so now the blue
ones are starting to take over
guys that the gray antibody that weren't
those are very good they're gone
completely one second and the amazing
thing is well let me just ask you does
this remind you of anything that you've
heard about in biology yeah I know you
know the answer hold on let's see if
anybody else does hold on you've
answered a lot of questions in it does
this process of mutation followed by the
preferential outgrowth of the better
ones that take over the population to
remind you of anything yep natural
selection the biggie guys this is
evolution going on in your body every
time you get an infection every time you
encounter a bacterium or a virus it
triggers your b-cells to turn on this
mutator and you have molecular and
cellular evolution going on in your body
yeah question
yeah so you can imagine hey this guy's
got a bad mutation for this virus but
maybe it was good for another virus the
problem is the immune system just
doesn't have time to wait around for
that virus to come along come along it's
it's too random and almost certainly
these guys would get lost in the shuffle
and die because this is the virus du
jour as you we say like this is the one
you care about today and it's not going
to just hang around those b-cells and
hope that another virus comes along but
it is possible I just don't know if it
ever happening another question great
question the normal b-cell remember
those B cells that didn't grab on to the
virus they were the ones that that like
just floated away they will live for
about two months and then they die and
they're replaced by the generation of
new B cells that are produced in our
bone marrow but these eyes that are
evolving into higher and higher but a
tighter what we call affinity tighter
binding after about two weeks of this
mutation and cell division this
evolution process you contain a lot of B
cells that can make great antibodies
okay here are now these blue and red
antibodies they're great antibodies and
you can just see if you get infected
again that virus remember it goes from
person number one to person number two
to person number three to four and then
it comes back to person number one again
person number one is ready because
person number one is filled up with
great antibodies the virus comes along
the antibodies latch on won't let go
destroy the virus
and you probably never even knew you
were infected at this point the
antibodies and the b-cells are so
effective that they just destroy the
virus now what was the question
you think about that and I don't go on
for just a second okay the very very
important thing we were talking about
some b-cells that only live for two
months but some of these great b-cells
that evolve in your body they can live
for years even your whole life
those b-cells a second for all this time
that those B cells are alive they will
protect you against that particular
virus now does this remind you of
something that that that we have we a
pet we've taken advantage of this is
immune system memory but how do how do
we take advantage of memory the immune
systems memory to protect us against
disease yeah that seems vaccines are the
are our way of tricking the immune
system into thinking you've been
infected with a particular bacterium or
virus and you don't get sick when you
get the vaccine but your immune system
does this whole amazing thing of
generating great antibodies and memory B
cells that live for years or your whole
life and so if you ever do get infected
with the real bacterium or virus you
don't get sick and vaccines are
incredibly important they have
eliminated smallpox from the planet they
we are on the verge of eliminating polio
from the entire world and vaccines
prevent millions of illnesses and
thousands of deaths every year and this
is how they work question
that's a great question and the answer
is first of all how not a doctor and so
I can't really I can't really recommend
anything and and and there's there's so
many ideas and and that's an area of
really there's all sorts of things like
stress we know that stress is bad for
your immune system so I can recommend
not being stressed but that's easier to
say than to do all right so let me just
summarize and out then I'll take
questions when I'm done but there's a
couple more things I want to say let me
remind you where we've been today the
genes that make antibodies do two
amazing unique things there are no other
cells in our body with the exception of
T cells which I'm not going to go into
that do anything like this one of those
amazing unique things as they take in a
gene that's broken up into little pieces
and they put the gene together and
that's how we can make billions of
antibodies and the second thing is they
then turn on a mutator to try to find an
antibody that's even better and the
antibodies cells and high affinity
antibodies that will provide this long
lasting memory the memory of what you
saw before so that you don't get sick
again and this is my moment where I just
want to say that we stand to Soaring
Crick lucky we get to explore the world
we get to see the mysteries the the
unknowns out in front of us and we get
to try to answer these questions and and
unravel the unknown and it is it is an
incredibly exciting thing to do it's
hard and it's frustrating and we do lots
of experiments that don't work but I
just want to urge you to think about how
fun and exciting
is to discover something that nobody
else on the planet knows and then even
better you get to go tell them about it
that is cool so let me say a few big
thank yous huge thank you to the members
of my lab past and present there lots of
I have a lab of about a dozen or 15
people that are amazing wonderful
scientists we've been studying these
processes that cut mutate the DNA for
twenty years and I hope we'll do it for
another twenty years I want to thank my
family especially my wife and daughter
who helped me a lot in putting this this
talk together so thank you yep and this
is very important for you guys to think
about I want to thank my funding
agencies the guy the folks who give me
the money to do the research the
National Institutes of Health you might
not realize it but that's you you guys
through your taxes pay me to do what I
do and I thank you I thank you I thank
you because without that government
support the research Enterprise in the
United States would crumble and I also
get a bunch of money from the Howard
Hughes Medical Institute and I thank
them as well and that by the way is not
coming out of your pocket so let me stop
there I will just remark ool cool cells
this is a picture of B cells very high
magnification they've been stained for
some proteins that help give the B cell
shape
there's tubulin and actin and this is
actually a B cell that's in the process
of dividing one B cell becoming two and
so I'll be happy to take questions thank
you
you